ORGANIZATION WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE THE
COBIT EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY. TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THAT'S EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
876-894-1876. EIGHT NINE FOUR
ONE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE
SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE REFER TO
THE SENATE INDOOR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL
BE I'M YOU DID AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST VIEW THE DEVICE THAT YOU
ARE WHAT. YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THIS YEAR
HEARING. AS IS CUSTOMARY N ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IT IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIFETIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE JUST A- TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL OF
PATIENTS SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. AB WE HAVE NINE BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA- BEFORE- WE
HAD HERE PRESENTATION ON ANY
BILLS LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE DO SO- MR SECRETARY
CAN WE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
DODD HERE DOT HERE NIELSEN-
HERE NIELSEN HERE ALLEN. ALLEN
HERE ARCHULETA. BAKER WHEN.
YOUR BAKER BARGES. BRADFORD
GLAZERWESO IF WEST OF HERE
GIANLUIGI AIR JONES HERE
KAMLAGER HERE KAMLAGER HERE
MELENDEZ. PORTANTINO HERE
PORTANTINO HERE RUBIO. RUBIO
HERE WILL PRESENT WELL HERE WE
HAVE A CORN GERM ORDERS IN A
SECTARIAN NOTES OF WARM IS
FINISHED. MEMBERS PLAN FOR
TODAY TO BEGIN WITH OUR CONSENT
ITEMS THEN MOVING THROUGH THE
AGENDA IN FILE ORDER AFTER EACH
BILLS PRESENTED WE WILL PLACE
THE BILL ON CALL AFTER ALL
BILLS HAVE BEEN HEARD I WILL
OPEN THE ROLL CALL ON EACH BILL
ONCE AGAIN TO GIVE A MEMBERS
WHO ARE ANOTHER COMMITTEES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE. ON TODAY'S
BILLS. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THERE ARE FIVE
BILLS ON THE CONSENT. THEY ARE
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FOUR
FIFTY. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB EIGHT
SEVENTEEN. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB EIGHT. EIGHTEEN THE
FILE ITEM NINE SB EIGHT TWENTY.
CAN I HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DO FROM CENTER
WILL THANK YOU- WE HAVE A
MOTION- COMMITTEE M. SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I'M ON A
CONTENT CALENDAR STARTED. BY
DOT HI NIELSEN ALL RIGHT
NIELSEN HI ALAN. ALLEN HI ARE
CHIRLA. BAKER HI BAKER I
GORGEOUS. GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD.
GLAZER WESO. JONES HI JONES I'D
COME OVER I KAMLAGER I KNOW.
ORANGE PORTANTINO HIGHER. RUBIO
I WILL WELCOME. I HAVE CENTER
PUT IT ON THAT'S TEN THAT HAS
TEN THAT WOULD PUT ON OKAY
LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FOR AUTHOR
DR PANDA MAY BEGIN FILE I
NUMBER SB SEVENTEEN SIR THANK
YOU CHAIR DIED AND SENATORS I'M
PLEASE PRESENT SB SEVENTEEN
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH AN OFFICE
OF RACIAL EQUITY AND RACIAL
EQUITY ADVISORY ACCOUNTABILITY
COUNCIL NOR TO ADDRESS SYSTEMIC
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM THAT
RESULTED IN POOR HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND DISPARITIES AND
THE STATE I FIRST WANT TO BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE MEN AND
SUBSCRIBE TO THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND A SEVEN YEAR
SUNSETCLAUSE AS PROPOSED. BY
THE COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS
LONG OVERDUE. IS A DOWN PAYMENT
TOWARDS STATE PLAYING A MORE
ACTIVE ROLE IN DISMANTLING OVER
THREE HUNDRED YEARS OF RACIAL
INEQUITIES IN ENDING SYSTEMIC
RACISM. EXTENSIVE RESEARCH HAS
IDENTIFIED RACISM IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS LEADING TO
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH DISPARITIES
INCLUDING INFANT AND MATERNAL
MORTALITY CHRONIC DISEASE
PREVALENCE. BUT EXPECTANCY AND
NOW COVERED MORTALITY. LAST
YEAR ACTUALLY THIS PAST YEAR
PANDEMIC LAID BARE SYSTEMIC
INEQUITIES THAT RUN DEEP IN OUR
SOCIETY AND INSTITUTIONS. AT
THE SAME TIME LAST SUMMER WE
SAW THE SURGEONS OF RACIAL
JUSTICE PROTEST HIS BONTA
MURDERS OF FLOYD BEYOND A
TAILOR AND SO MANY MORE. AND
AGAIN WE ARE NOW SEEING ANOTHER
RISE OF VIOLENCE AND HATRED
TOWARD THE EIGHTY I COMMUNITY.
THANK RECENTLY DAILY TIMES
REPORTED ON THE HISTORY OF ANTI
ASIAN SENTIMENTS AND POLICIES
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THE VERY LONG HISTORY OF THIS.
IN MANY WAYS THESE INCIDENTS
WHILE CALLING UNFORTUNATELY ARE
NEITHER NEW NOR SURPRISING. AND
THE CONDITIONS THAT LED TO
THESE INEQUITIES HAVE BEEN
BREWING FOR A LONG TIME. IT WAS
CERTAINLY THE STATE HAS MADE
EFFORTS TECHNOLOGY CONFRONT
RACIAL DISPARITIES. RECENT
YEARS EQUITIES OFTEN TREATED AS
AN AFTERTHOUGHT OR IS A SILENT
STRATEGY. IT'S NOT JUST ENOUGH
TO DECLARE RACISM AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS IS SO MANY OF OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. HAVE HAVE
DONE AND DISCUSS OTHER PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE WE MUST ALSO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. THE
STATE NEEDS AN INDEPENDENT BODY
TO HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE BY SAMMY
CALIFORNIA'S POLICIES AND
BUDGET WITH THE GOAL OF
ACHIEVING RACIAL EQUITY IN
ENDING SYSTEMIC RACISM. THIS
BILL- ESTABLISH OFFICE RACIAL
EQUITY TO LEAVE THIS WORK IN A
POWER TO STATE TO IMPLEMENT A
RACIAL EQUITY FRAMEWORK. SB
SEVENTEEN IS SPONSORED BY THE
ADVANCE PROJECT CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COALITION GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE NEXT GEN
POLICY PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES
AND THE ACLU STATE COUNCIL. THE
SUPPORT BY A WIDE ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING LABOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ADVOCATES.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
EALTH PROVIDERS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SB SEVENTEEN AND
SUPPORT THE BILL I HAVE. TO
WITNESSES. VERA SANCHEZ FROM
THE GREEN LINING INSTITUTE AND
JOHN KIM FUND ADVANCEMENT
PROJECT CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILL NOW MOVE
ON ANYONE WANTED TESTIFIED
SUPPORT FOR THOSE- SPEAKERS DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS- REGARDING THE
LATE THE HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS A CLEANING
PRODUCT ALL PROTOCOLS. I'M
LIMITING TESTIMONY BY. EITHER
SIDE TO THREE MINUTES- ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION. THAT POSITION
ON- THE MEASURE. SO MISTER
SANCHEZ OR MR KIM EITHER ONE
WHO WANTS TO GO FIRST- YOU'RE
ON. YES THAT THANK YOU- MY NAME
IS LITTLE SENSE- THE PRICE PER
ON THE POLICY HAD CLEANING IS A
TWO. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY BECOMES A OF THIS
SEVEN. I SWITCHED THE BAND WITH
A BAND MAKES IT CHAU- THE OF
RACE AND THAT IN AMERICA TELLS.
AN ASSISTANT MY TRACKS ON
PEOPLE OF COLOR BEING HIT THE
HARDEST A NUMBER OF KEY. THAT
ANY CLASSES. ASIAN AMERICAN
HAVE BEEN. LEADING TO. VIOLENCE
TO THE EIGHT I CAN IN THE HOME
ACT. THAT TOOK PLACE IN THE
PLAN ACTED THE LIVES SIX EACH
WOMEN. IN DIGITAL AND READ THAT
FOLLOWED THEM OF THREE TAYLOR
INTELLECTUAL AND OTHERS I'M-
THE WAY THAT OUR THAT OUR
NATION HAS BEEN SAID. RACISM SO
RESPONSE MUST BE EQUAL IF AND
HOW WE DISMANTLE RACIAL IN. THE
DEEP RACIAL INEQUITIES ARE
CURRENTLY EXISTING INSTITUTE.
ARE NOT GOING TO THEM SO. THEY
ARE TO. OF DECADES OF
GOVERNMENT AND GO. POLICY
IMPACT. EVEN IF DEMONSTRATED
ROLE IN CREATING A IMPLEMENTING
MANY OF THESE. GOVERNMENT
SHOULD HOLD A DIRECT ROLE IN
HELPING TO IDENTIFY. STYLE FOR
THE LIMITED. GENERATIONS OF
RACE BASED POLICIES THAT HAVE
HAD A DISPROPORTIONATE NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
LONG TERM THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY WILL TAKE A COORDINATED
APPROACH WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT. TO IDENTIFY RACIAL
DISPARITIES DEVELOP STRATEGIES
TO REDUCE AND ELIMINATE THIS
DISPARITIES. PROMOTE EQUITABLE
OUTCOMES AND CONTINUOUSLY
EVALUATE PROGRESS. I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF SB
SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER SANCHEZ MISTER KIM.
MONNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
IS JOHN CAMPANI AGGRESSIVE
PUNCH CALIFORNIA PROUD CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL. PROVIDING
EQUALLY FIRST COME FIRST SERVE
FOLLOWING THE LONG SANDING
RULES AND NORMS THESE ARE ALL
THINGS I CUT MY KIDS WHEN
PLAYING THE FRENCH THE
PLAYGROUND. BUT ALL TOO OFTEN
WE SEE THE SEEMINGLY INNOCENT
APPROACH TO POLICY MAKING THE
STATE. OF FOR THE RELEASE
SCHOOL OVERCROWDING WAS
DISTRIBUTED FIRST COME FIRST
SERVED FOUR YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA. GUESS WHAT SUBURBAN
DISTRICTS THAT AMPLE ACCESS TO
LAND AND FUNDING FOR CONSOLES
WERE ALWAYS FIRST IN LINE.
THEREFORE THE LEAST OVERCROWDED
DISTRICTS WE'RE GETTING THE
LION'S SHARE OF OVERCROWDING
RELIEF DOLLARS. THIS IS NOT IN
THE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS THIS IS
IN THE TWO THOUSAND AND IT WAS
NOT INTENTIONAL THAT FUND.
BELIEVE ACTUAL OUTCOME OF
PLAYGROUND POLICY MAKE. AN
OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY IS NOT
ABOUT FINDING ONE OR TWO BAD
APPLES IT IS THE REALIZATION
THAT WE HAVE INHERITED A SYSTEM
THAT NO LONGER REFLECTS WHO WE
ARE STATE. ALLOWED TO
INTERROGATE INSTITUTIONAL
RACISM AND HELP US FIND A WAY
FOR WITH THIS BILL DISABLED
MORE CONSISTENTLY MAKE
DECISIONS THAT ACCOUNT FOR
HISTORY. RESPONSIVE DATA AND
RESPONSIBLE VOICES THE PRESENCE
OF MOST HARD BY OUR PAST
MISTAKES I. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU
MISTER. NOW IT'S HERE THERE IS
NO- IN THE NO WITNESSES IN THE
CASE. LOOKING AT- ROOM TWELVE I
AM C. NOBODY- SO- WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCES
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
SEVENTEEN WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE TWENTY
SIX LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
TERRACE AT BRAMBLE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT BIGGER.
NINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THE EX. NINE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CAMPBELL
RECALLED PLYMOUTH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MARIN THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
I'M SORRY DOCTORS COULD PLEASE
JUST PROCEED THROUGH AS PEOPLE
LIVE HANG UP YOU CAN JUST CALL
IT OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ADRIAN SHELTON
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE A CHILD FAMILY
SERVICES WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB SEVENTEEN THANK YOU.
MY TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
COMMISSION SHALL DEAL ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA. IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE SOVIET POLICE
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
WORK THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JENNIFER LORIEN BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANYONE
WITH THEIR CA YOU CALIFORNIA
PROCONSULAR IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES WHOSE A
CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS. NINE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS EUGENE KANSEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DONNA CENTER PRESENTING A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SHARE NUMBERS THIS
IS ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THE CHASING
BARBERS WITH THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS THINK THE
BOOK. THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS WILLIAM UPTON
BURKE ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND THE BLACK
AFRICAN AMERICAN LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
MAX CARRY ON THE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION FOR A LATE NIGHT
COMMISSION OF SUPPORT TODAY BUT
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MOLLY
WRITTEN WITH A PARENT HAD
AFFILIATE THE CALIFORNIA IN
COURT. THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING STRUCTURE
MEMBERS THIS IS JANE ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTOR ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA QUARTERBACKS THE
SEVENTY. THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
RICHARD ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
THE ARK AND UNITED CEREBRAL
PALSY CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
CAN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA THE
COUNTY WLFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CAROLINA SANTAMARINA
WITH NEXT IN CALIFORNIA PROUD
BECAUSE THE PORT THANK YOU. MY
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHAT
GIACALONE BAPTIST THE CHURCH OF
YANOMAMI IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JIM WEINBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SECRETARY
MEMBERS DANNY OFFER WITH THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS ALSO KNOWN AS NOT MAKE
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WE OF CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
KEYS THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING IF YOU
CAN'T UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR-
APPRECIATE THAT- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE NOW- TO- THE OPEN- WHO
LIVES TO- HERE FROM- YOU'VE
MADE FROM ANY OPPOSITION- THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY- THERE APPEARS TO BE
NOBODY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE CAN
WE OPEN THE LINES AT THIS POINT
TIME TO- SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY.
VIA THE TELESERVICES CONFERENCE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVENTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THIS IS JULIA
KAPLAN WITH THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE IN THE COURT. OKAY
APPRECIATE THAT SUPPORT WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME A
MODERATOR DIE HOW MANY CALLS
ARE WAITING FOR OPPOSITION. TO
SB SEVENTEEN. WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVENTEEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE MEMBERS DO ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. UP I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I
DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THE POINT
AS I THINK OTHERS SPEAKERS AS
WELL AS THE AUTHOR DID A GREAT
JOB OF HIGHLIGHTING WHY THIS
IS. IMPORTANT AS WE KNOW THAT
RACIAL AND HOLD DISPARITIES
EXIST AND ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC IT'S BEEN EXTREMELY
CLEAR THAT- COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR MINORITY COMMUNITIES ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE HARDEST HIT.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
SOMETHING IN ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS SET AND MEENA KNOWING
THAT RACE ON HEALTH DISPARITIES
EXIST RESPONSE HAS TO BE. THIS
MONTH SYSTEMATIC I'M SORRY IT
WILL BE SYSTEMATIC IN TERMS OF
IDENTIFYING DEVELOPING
STRATEGIES. AND ELIMINATING
WASTE ON HOLD DISPARITIES SELL
WITHOUT- I WANT BY LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CLOCK WHEN APPROPRIATE AND WITH
THAT I WANT TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
THE- DOCTOR PAN BEFORE- WE GO
TO THE VOTE- FOR THE RECORD I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
ARE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS ON
PAGE TEN OF THE ANALYSIS AS
WELL AS THE- SEVEN YEAR SUNSET
CORRECT YES CORRECT. WHAT I'M
SORRY MR BECK CENTER BACKER I
DID NOT SEE THAT MICROPHONE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR JUST A
QUICK COMMENT AS WELL TO THANK
THE AUTHOR- IT'S OF COURSE VERY
TIMELY. BILL AND A SYSTEMIC
PROBLEM REQUIRES A SYSTEMIC
RESPONSE AND THAT'S WHY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO BE. ADDED TO A CO
AUTHOR IF YOU'RE ACCEPTING CO
AUTHORS AND I. APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATION. FANTASTIC SENATOR.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR I'M
IT'S TIME FOR SOMEONE SPEAK FOR
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND OUR CONSTITUTION. YOU MAY
HAVE ISSUES WITH OUR
CONSTITUTION THAT GOES BACK
OVER TWO HUNDRED YEARS. THE
FOUNDERS ANTICIPATED THAT AND
SET IN PLACE MECHANISMS FOR
THAT CONSTITUTION TO BE AMENDED
BE IT THE DESIRE. WE COME FROM
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
WITH VERY FEW AMENDMENTS. MOST
ALL OF BEEN VERY POSITIVE
AMENDMENTS. IT SEEMS LIKE ALL
OF A SUDDEN HERE IN AMERICA
WE'RE ON A- GREAT RUSH. THE
PURGE OUR HISTORY BECAUSE FROM
BODIES PEARL DO NOT LIKE
ELEMENTS OF OUR HISTORY. I DO
NOT LIKE SOME ELEMENTS OF OUR
HISTORY. BUT THIS COUNTRY HAS
SURVIVED AND PROSPERED. FOR ALL
OF THESE DECADES VERY WELL. AS
AN EXAMPLE. TO THE WORLD. OF
GOODNESS KINDNESS BENEVOLENCE
RESPECT. DAVID CHERRY PICK ALL
YOU WANT IS THE FINDING HERE DO.
AND CONDEMN ALL YOU WANT. BUT I
SUBMIT. OUR CONSTITUTION IS
QUITE SOUND. AND THERE'S STILL
ORDER THE SWELLED THROUGH THE
DECADES AS HAS THE CALIFORNIA.
CONSTITUTION. HERE WE CHANGE IT
MORE OFTEN THAN NATIONALLY. AS
WELL WE SHOULD I SUPPOSE. BUT I
CAN'T ABIDE WITH THIRTEEN PAGES
OF CHERRY PICKED EXAMPLES. OF
WHAT SOME DETERMINAR BAD
SOMEBODY'S I DETERMINAR BAD.
BUT DO WE WANT TO REINVENT OUR
HISTORY. FRANKLY ONE OF THE
MOST NEGLECTED PARTS OF
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA IS
HISTORY. OUR YOUTH ARE NOT
IMBUED WITH A SENSE OF HISTORY.
AND THIS HAS BEEN CONVEYED VERY
OFTEN TO ME BY HISTORY
PROFESSORS. AND TEACHERS. WE
WANT TO REWRITE HISTORY. I DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE
WAY TO DO IT. THEY WANT TO
STAND UP FINE NOW TO THE
ELEMENTS OF THE BILL. AT THE
SAME ESTIMATED THE GOVERNOR
MIGHT HAVE SOME PROBLEMS HERE
BECAUSE IF YOU SEARCH THE
GOVERNOR'S AUTHORITY. ALL THE
GOVERNOR DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
RELUCTANT TO USURP LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY THESE DAYS. BUT IT
DOES IT GIVES JUST. IT THIRTY.
THE ABILITY TO CONTROL OTHER
AGENCIES. TO A BLANK CHECK THE
BUDGETS OF OTHER AGENCIES. IN
THIS AGENCY IS RECORDED ALMOST
A BLANK CHECK IN THE BUDGET. I
WILL BE UNKNOWABLE. SIR CALM
WATER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND EITHER WAY WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
M. AND I WANT I APPRECIATE THE-
AUTHOR FOR- BRINGING THIS. BILL
FORWARD I WANTED TO ASK I AM
ACTUALLY HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR- ABOUT SORT OF THE
COORDINATED INTEGRATED
APPROACH- THAT THIS OFFICE
WOULD HAVE I THINK OFTEN TIMES
WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT AND
TALKING ABOUT RACIAL EQUITY-
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THE TOP
LINE ISSUES CRIMINAL JUSTICE
HEALTH CARE RACIAL VIOLENCE BUT
WE'VE NOTICED AND WE KNOW THAT-
THEIR RACIAL INEQUITIES THAT
HAPPENED IN EDUCATION AND
TRANSPORTATION AND NOW
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS ARE
GIVEN OUT. IN A DEVELOPMENT
CONSTRUCTION HOUSING X. SENTARA
AND- IT WOULD BE. I THINK THE
STATE WOULD BE REMISS TO HAVE
AN OFFICE A NEWLY CREATED
OFFICE THAT OPERATES IN A SILO-
AND THAT ISN'T LOOKING TO SORT
OF INTEGRATE IN INFUSE- EITHER
THESE KINDS OF- METRICS OR
QUESTIONS OR BENCHMARKS THAT WE
SHOULD REALLY BE APPLYING
ACROSS THE BOARD IN ALL OF THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE RUN BY THE
STATE. SO I WAS WONDERING IF
YOU COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT AND THEN GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THERE WILL BE A
SUNSET WITH SEVEN YEARS AND I
CERTAINLY DON'T THINK THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CURE AND THE
CHALLENGES WITH OF RACIAL
INEQUITY IN SEVEN YEARS. WHAT
WOULD BE THE PLAN TO SORT OF-
INTEGRATE YOU KNOW SO THAT IF
IT DOES DISSOLVE THERE ARE
STILL THE ELEMENTS OF THE
OFFICE THAT ARE PERMEATING- YOU
KNOW ACROSS ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS. OF COURSE THERE IS
AN OPPORTUNITY I'M SURE EXTEND
THE SUNSET BUT IF THAT WERE NOT
TO HAPPEN HOW WOULD WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE STILL ABLE TO
SAVE AND USE- AND EXPANDON THE
WORK THAT WILL BE HAPPENING IN
THIS OFFICE. I THINK YOU-
CENTER CALLING FOR- FOR THE
QUESTION- FIRST OF ALL- I THINK
THE INTENT OF THE SUNSETS AS
WORKING AS A IF I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH A CHAIR IS
REALLY TO FOR- AND OPTING FOR
REVIEW- TO EXAMINE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE OFFICE SEE
THERE'S ADJUSTMENTS WE NEED TO
MAKE. TO THE LEGISLATION
SOUNDING THIS OFFICE IN TERMS
OF INSPECTORS MOVING FORWARD SO
AT LEAST I CERTAINLY HOPE
PERSONALLY THAT- THE PURPOSE OF
THE SUNSET IS NOT TO TERMINATE
THE OFFICE AT THAT TIME BUT TO
IMPROVE IT AND AT NOW THAT WE
HAD. THAT TIME LESSONS I DO
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR WORKING
WITH ME TO MAKE IT A SEVEN YEAR
SUNSET TO GET SUFFICIENT TIME
FOR THIS OFFICE TO. BE ABLE TO-
LUNCH IT'S INITIAL WORK
SUPPORTERS OPPORTUNITIES ENOUGH
SO THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
GOOD VALUE AND GOOD EVALUATION
BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT GONNA
SOLVE SYSTEMIC RACISM IN SEVEN
YEARS- AND NOT ALL. DEAL PART
IS YOU MEANT IS THAT- TO A OF
EXAMPLE DO AN OFF OF. EQUITY
AND THE HEALTH HUMAN. AND
HEALTH EQUITY BUT AGAIN THE
SILO IN ISSUE IS VERY IMPORTANT
SO FOR EXAMPLE WE CAN THINK
ABOUT CERTAIN HOUSING POLICIES
THEN UNDERMINING- ACTUALLY
WEALTH'S. CONTINUATION BY THAT
BY- ACTUALLY BLACK AMERICANS
AND OTHER. ANGEL GROUPS AS WELL
THEN WHICH THEN HAS.
CONSEQUENCES FOR. NOT ONLY
ACTUALLY HEALTHY I CONSEQUENCES
IT ALSO HAS OTHER TYPES OF
CONSEQUENCES IN TERMS OF WELLS
INTERLOCKING FINE AND SO FORTH
SO THESE. POLICIES IN ONE SILO
CAN HAVE TREMENDOUS IMPACTS IN
OTHERS AND I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING IS BEEN RECOGNIZED BY
PEOPLES- IS THE MANY LOCALITIES
HAVE DECLARED RACE RACISM IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS A BACKGROUND PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE KNOW THAT-
OFTENTIMES. YEAH WE HAVE TO
LOOK ACROSS THE SYSTEM THAT WHY
CALL SYSTEMIC RACISM RAPE-
BECAUSE AND OFTENTIMES AND WHAT
WE NEED TO DO IS WE NEED TO
BETTER BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
AND MEASURE IT. RIGHT AND IN
MANY WAYS THIS OFFICE ONLY A
FIRST STEP RIGHT THIS OFFICE
GONNA LOOK AT TRADE ABOUT
MEASURES. GET YOU'LL BE SITTING
IN COULD. BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
THE DATA AND THEN MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN IT'S
GOING TO BE OUR JOBS AS A
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AND SO FORTH AND THEN TAKE
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS AND YOU
KNOW ENACT THEM AND MOVE THEM
FORWARD. RIGHT BUT IF YOU DON'T
LOOK AT YOU DON'T DEFINE THE
PROBLEM EXAMINE THE PROBLEM THE
FIRST PLACE YOU CAN TAKE STEPS
TO ADDRESS IT AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THIS OFFICE WHAT THIS BILL
IS. ABOUT GETTING THAT FIRST
STEP JUST LIKE IF YOU TRY IT
YOU KNOW AND A PANDEMIC OR YOU
SEE- WHAT HOW DO WE REDUCE SO
IT'S A HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE OR
ANY OTHER THINGS REPUBLICAN
STANDPOINT FIRST THING YOU GOT
TO DO IS- THAT IS ACTUALLY
GATHERS THE DATA TO FIND A
SOCIAL STRATEGY IN AND- OF
COURSE GET THE POLITICAL WILL
TO SOLVE IT AND I'M ACTUALLY
QUITE ACTIVE PARAPHRASING AS
SURGEON GENERAL JULIUS RICHMOND
WHO WAS A MENTOR OF MINE. IN
TERMS OF HOW TO ESTABLISH GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY TO TRY TO.
IMPROVE HEALTH SO- SO THANK YOU.
SO MUCH FOR YOUR QUESTION.
CENTER THANK YOU- BORDERS.
THANK YOU. MAN POSE A QUESTION
TO AUTHOR SURE THAT WOULD
ACCEPT. WHAT IS THE ANTICIPATED
COST FOR CREATING THIS
COMMISSION. ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
SO WERE AT FIRST WELL I GUESS
WE'RE WE'RE STILL WORKING THAT
OUT ACTUALLY IS WE'RE HAVING
DISCUSSIONS- ON THE BUDGET AS
WELL AS- APPROPRIATIONS AND SO
I SEE COMMISSION ITSELF- IS IN
ITSELF- NOT TERRIBLY EXPENSIVE
YEAH WE HAVE MANY WE DO HAVE
OTHER CONDITIONS BUT I THINK
THE REAL PART IS THE WORK TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE DAY TO DATA
ANALYSIS CERTAINLY OUR STATE
COLLECTS A LOT OF DATA. IN FACT
ACTUALLY A PREVIOUSLY OFF AND-
OPEN DATA LOSS TO TRY TO MAKE
THAT DATA MORE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC- BUT THEN WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE ANALYTICAL
CAPACITY AS WELL AS WELL TO DO
THAT AND SO- WE ARE- OF
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THE- THE-
THE FISCAL PART I'D REALIZING
THAT THIS IS A- YOU KNOW A
POLICY COMMITTEE DID DID NOT.
HAVE THE ANALYSIS YET- TRUE AND
PROCREATION AND CERTAINLY
WORKING WHETHER THE CHAIR
PROCREATION CENTER PORTANTINO
WE WILL WORK OUT A MORE
DETAILED US AT FISCAL
ASSISTANCE TERMS OF WHAT THE
COST WOULD BE FOR- THIS BILL.
ABOUT BALLPARK FIGURE. WELL I
THINK I INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
SPEC. ON THAT- I THINK WHEN IT
GETS YEN GOES. TO
APPROPRIATIONS BUDGET WE CAN
GET A MORE SPECIFIC I'M YOU CAN
SCALE IT IN DIFFERENT SCALES
ARE- IN TERMS OF- THE DEFIANCE
OF THE QUESTIONS HOWHOW. WHAT
DEGREE ARE WE- GOING TO SKATE
AT WHAT SCALE ARE GOING TO DO
THIS SO- I'M GONNA ASK A CENTER
PORTANTINO TO COMMENT. BUT JUST
FOR THAT FOR THOSE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A DON'T KNOW. THIS IS A
COMMITTEE HEARING SO YOU'RE
FREE. TO DIRECTOR COMMENTS TO-
THE AUTHORED ANYTIME. WITHOUT
GOING THROUGH THE CHAIR. SO-
CENTER PORTANTINO YEAH I WAS
JUST GONNA SAY SO WE HAVE NOT
DONE A THE FULL COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS BECAUSE THE BILL
HASN'T LEFT THIS COMMITTEE YET
BUT REST ASSURED WE WILL AND
THAT'LL BE MADE AVAILABLE AND
IS THE AUTHOR STATED TYPICALLY
THESE ARE NOT SUPER EXPENSIVE-
PROGRAMS BUT- I'M HAPPY ONCE
THE ANALYSIS IS COMPLETE TO
SHARE THAT WITH YOU SENATOR. BY
ALL MEANS THANK YOU. I THINK
THE- YOU SPEAK INTO THE MIKE
PLEASE- SELF IMAGE OF MY OF MY
LAST QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
THIS OFFICE OF RICK RACIAL
EQUITY WOULD. PUT FORWARD OR
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO BOTH
THE EXECUTIVE AS WELL AS THE AS
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH'S
POSSIBLY EVEN. THE ENTIRE
BREADTH OF. DIVISIONS OF THE
STATE IS THAT CORRECT. YES
SEVEN MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
WHICH OF COURSE WOULD GO TO THE
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE JUST LIKE MANY
OTHER COMMISSIONS WOULD ALL
RIGHT IN WITH IT. WITH THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS BE LIMITED TO-
PIECES OF LEGISLATION TO ENACT-
POLICY WITHIN THE DIVISIONS OF
THE STATE OR COULD THEY BE
DIRECTED IT SEPARATELY TO
REGULATORY BODIES THAT WOULD BY
PASS THE LEGISLATURE. WELL I
THINK THAT ANY REGULATORY BODY
HAS TO WORK WITHIN THE
CONSTRAINTS OF THE- THE CODE
WHICH WE OF COURSE PASSES THE
LEGISLATURE AND SO- IN MY EIGHT
TIMES BODIES TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN
BETWEEN IT AND THE DIALOGUE
BETWEEN NOT EXECUTIVE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE- WE HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WHAT WOULD
WE DO WITH THE WITH THAT
PARTICULAR RECOMMENDATION AND-
OFTENTIMES WE WILL ACT AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO. EITHER PUSH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DO SOMETHING
OR EVEN LIMITED MINISTRATION
FROM DOING SOMETHING WE DON'T
AGREE WITH SO I THINK THAT'S
PART OF THE NORMAL POLICY
MAKING PROCESS. SO HERE ALL IN
ALL FINISH HERE. ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE IS BECAUSE
OF THIS HAS. EXPANSIVE
JURISDICTIONAL AUTHORITY THAT
REACHES TO ALL DIVISIONS
POTENTIALLY OF THE STATE. AS
WELL AS ALL THREE BRANCHES OF
OUR GOVERNMENT. THAT THERE BE A
FORMAL SYSTEM IN IT THIS WOULD
ALL THIS BE LIKE A FRIENDLY I
REQUEST FOR AMENDMENT. THAT AS
THIS MOVES FORWARD TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THAT IT BE
AMENDED THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TAKE A
FORMALITY MEANING THAT IN ONE
DOCUMENT WETHERBY ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS OR EVERY NUMBER OF YEARS
ANY RECOMMENDATIONS BE
CONSOLIDATED SO WE THEY CAN BE
KEPT TRACK OF BECAUSE MY
CONCERN IS THAT A COMMISSION
LIKE THIS IS GOING TO SIPHON
OUT. IN SELECT IN TARGETED WAYS
OVER SEVEN YEAR PERIOD OF TIME
AND WE'RE THE PUBLIC AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
TRACK OF EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS
BEING- HOW THIS IS BEING
CONDUCTED IN A WAY THAT IS
HOLISTIC AND COMPREHENSIVE. SO
I'LL LEAVE THAT UP TO YOU IF
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
THINK. COULD IMPROVE UPON.
CERTAIN CERTAINLY THE
GOVERNMENT COMMISSIONED- ISSUED
ITS RECOMMENDATION SHOULD BE A
MATTER OF PUBLIC RECORD AND-
STUDENTS HAVE TO BE ORGANIZED
IN A WAY THAT COULD BE EASILY
REFERENCED BY OTHERS- THOUGH
THE PUBLIC AS WELL AS COURSE-
POLICYMAKERS AND- CERTAINLY
WILL- TAKE THAT SUGGESTION TO
HEART- WE'LL SEE WHETHER DEBT
TO. BE THE PUT IN THE CODE BUT
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO HAVE A
DIALOGUE WITH YOU- THAT THAT
BUT I WOULD IMAGINE ANY PUBLIC
COMMISSION PUTTING THIS ONE
SHOULD CERTAINLY MAKE ITS
RECOMMENDATIONS. I REALLY
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC AS WELL
AS TO- THE LEGISLATURE AND
INDEPENDENT ADMINISTRATION. AND
SO I HEARKEN BACK TO WHAT- MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENT. THAT I'M
SUPER. I KNOW THE NEED IS THERE
I KNOW THE CIRCUMSTANCES. ARE
ENCOURAGING US TO LOOK AT THE
QUALITY AND EQUITY RELATED
ISSUES- I'M STILL A LITTLE HARD
PRESSED TO NOT BELIEVE THAT THE
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE
HAVE. HAS THE INSTRUMENTS THAT
ARE CAPABLE OF ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE. ALREADY WITHOUT
NECESSARILY CREATING A BRAND
NEW COMMISSION- BECAUSE THIS IS
THE ISSUE OF SILO. THINKING CAN
EASILY BE OVERCOME BY AN INTER
DISCIPLINARY DIRECTIVE FROM THE
GOVERNOR WITHIN THE EXISTING
DIVISIONS OF THE STATE RIGHT
NOW THE- BUT THAT WAS THE SITE
OF ON IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY SO I'M YOU KNOW JUST
MAKES- MY COMMENTS YOU KNOW I
TOOK A LOOK AT THIS AND YOU
KNOW THAT'S ONE OF THE
JURISDICTIONS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. IS WHEN WE SET UP
NEW THINGS AND GOVERNMENT
AGENTS AGENCIES COMMISSIONS AT
CENTRE THEY FALL TO OUR
COMMITTEE THIS THIS BILL WILL
BE GOING TO THE JUDICIARY WHICH
WILL BE DOING A DEEPER DIVE IN
ISSUES LIKE THIS. AND FOR A
FRANKLY I WAS MOVED BY THIS
BILL ACTUALLY AS A RESULT OF
THE FACT THAT- THE COST TO THE
STATE IS SO LOW THE SITUATIONS
IN OUR COUNTRY AND- I THINK
EVEN IN OUR STATE. I THINK A
MORE ACCESS TO MORE
UNDERSTANDING OF- THE- THE
RACIAL INEQUITIES OR
DISCRIMINATION OR THE LIKE IN
OUR- IN OUR GOVERNMENT IN OUR
SOCIETY- ANY ATTENTION THAT WE
CAN PUT TO THAT IN A POSITIVE
MANNER. TO CHANGE THINGS THAT
WE DO OR HOW WE ACT- YET ANY
INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENT TO BE BE
MADE AWARE IT'S PROBABLY NOT
PROBABLY IT'S A POTS THANK SO
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE DR PAN THANK YOU THANK
YOU- CHAIR DOT AND- I SHOULD
MENTION ALSO JUST- THAT.
THERE'S AN ANNUAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENT AND IN THE BILL
ALREADY SO THAT'S- READY PART
OF THE- THE BILL IN TERMS OF-
BUT MONEY COMMISSIONS DUTIES IS
TO DO ANNUAL REPORT- I WOULD
ALSO DID THANK. THE MEMBERS TO
THE SPOKEN ON THIS BILL I DO
WAY TO. AT ADDRESS THE ISSUE IN
TERMS OF- THEIR COUNTRIES HIS
BECAUSE- I'M A L. A. I'M A OF
IMMIGRANTS BUT I'M PROUD OF
THIS COUNTRY AND THERE'S A
REASON MY PARENTS CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY GREAT. IN FACT OUR
COUNTRY IS FOUNDED ON AN
ASPIRATION NOW WE MAY FEEL THAT
THE IN THE BEGINNING AND WE
SELL A LONG WAYS TO GO BUT WE
OUR ASPIRATION WAS EQUITY INTO
FOUND THE OUR FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS THE DECLARATION
INDEPENDENCE AND- WELL COULD
OF- MAJOR FOR ME THOMAS JESSICA
WORDED A LITTLE BETTER TO
ENSURE INCLUDE ONE AND THEY'LL
TALK ABOUT. EQUITY AND EQUALITY
IN OUR I WOULD MAKE THAT THAT
OUR CONSTITUTION A DOCUMENT
THAT CERTAINLY I HOLD VERY
DEAR- THE PREAMBLE STARTS OFF
WE THE PEOPLE THE UNITED STATES.
IN ORDER TO FORM A MORE PERFECT
UNION. ESTABLISH INSURED AND
TRANQUILITY PROVIDE FOR THE
COMMON DEFENSE PROMOTE THE
GENERAL WELFARE. RIGHT AND
SECURE THE BLESSINGS OF LIBERTY
TO OURSELVES AND OUR POSTERITY
DO ORDAIN AND ESTABLISH THE
CONSTITUTION THAT STATES SO-
YOU KNOW MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR SAID THAT THE MORAL ARC
OF THE UNIVERSE BENDS TOWARDS
JUSTICE. AS WE TALK ABOUT
JUSTICE THAT'S IN THE PREAMBLE
TO CONSTITUTION WE ALSO KNOW
THAT UNFORTUNATELY THAT DOES
NOT HAPPEN AUTOMATICALLY THAT
HAPPENS ONLY RESULT OF EFFORT
AND EVEN SACRIFICE. SO I WOULD
DO THAT SB SEVENTEEN IS A-
NOTHER STEP. IMPORTANT STEP BUT
ATTENDED A STEP. TOWARD
ACHIEVING THOSE ASPIRATIONS
THAT IDEAL OF OUR COUNTRY
THAT'S EMBODIED BOTH IN OUR IN
OUR FOUNDING DOCUMENTS. AND
THAT WE REALLY ARE ABOUT
CREATING A MORE PERFECT UNION
WHERE. EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES IN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY.
THAT WE CHIEF ACTITUD CHIEF
EQUITY AND TO BUILD A
PROSPEROUS HERE IN THIS GREAT
COUNTRY BUT THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. THANK YOU SENATOR-
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER RUBIO SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE SB SEVENTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE CANADIAN JUDICIARY DOT.
I THOUGHT I'D NIELSEN NO NO SIR
NO ALLEN. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA.
BAKER RIGHT BAKER I'VE WORKED.
BRADFORD GLAZER WESO. IT WAS I
WAS SO THAT'S JUST WHAT IT'S
ALL ON MY WAY SO I'D JONES NO
JONES NO KAMLAGER. I'M AYE
MELENDEZ. PORTANTINO I
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO HI HI
WELCOME. THAT SEVEN CHILDREN TO
THOSE- WILL PLACE A BILL ON
CALL NOW I WILL NOW PRESENT-
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FOUR
SEVENTEEN CENTER NIELSEN WILL
NOW PRESIDE. THURMOND DID YOU
LIKE TO BRING YOUR BILL. THE
FOUR SEVENTEEN YES SIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SB
FOUR SEVENTEEN ALLOWS HERE
COMMON CARRIERS THE ABILITY TO
TRACK IN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
INTO THE STATE FOR THE SOLE
PURPOSE LET ME JUST RESTATE
THAT THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
SERVING THAT ALCOHOL ON THEIR
AIRPLANES WITHOUT THE NEED TO
OBTAIN AN IMPORTER LICENSE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW YOUR COMMON
CARRIERS ALREADY ARE ALLOWED TO
BRING IN ALCOHOL GET TO THE
STATE FOR THAT PURPOSE WITHOUT
THE NEED TO OBTAIN AN IMPORTER
LICENSE HOWEVER CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES THAT OUT THAT ALCOHOL
TO BE BROUGHT IN ON THIS VERY
SAME AIRPLANES. IN WHICH THE
ALCOHOL IS SERVED. GIVEN THE
LOGISTICAL COMPLEXITY OF AIR
TRAVEL THIS GRIEF PROBLEMS FOR
AIRLINES BECAUSE OF THE NEED.
TO PLAY ON THE PATH OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES SO THAT
ENDS UP ON THE CORRECT FLIGHT
AT THE CORRECT PLACE AT THE
CORRECT TIME WHEN IT WILL BE
NEEDED. THIS BILL WILL SOLVE
THAT ISSUE BY ALLOWING AIRLINES
THE ABILITY TO TRACK IN ALCOHOL
FROM OUT OF STATE. THAT'S IT
ELSE'S POINTS OUT THOSE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES WOULD ONLY
BE ALLOWED TO BE SERVED ON
THOSE AIR COMMON CARRIERS
AIRPLANES IF THOSE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES ARE USED FOR ANY
OTHER PURPOSE. THESE ARE LIFE
WOULD BE A VIOLATION OF THE APC
ACT. SUCH A VIOLATION WOULD
RESULT IN THE DEPARTMENT OF A.
B. C. HAVING THE AUTHORITY TO
SEIZE THOSE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
AND INDIVIDUALS SHOULD COULD
BE. CHARGED WITH A MISDEMEANOR
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. AND DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITE ANY SUPPORTERS HERE IN
THE BUILDING I DO NOT SEE ANY.
IN THE GALLERY DO WE HAVE ANY
IN TWENTY FORTY. ANY OPPOSITION.
YES THE SUPPORT SUPPORTERS
ACCUSING. APPARENTLY NOT AND
THAT SAID IT. TO THE MODERATOR
DO YOU HAVE ANYONE IN QUEUE TO
SUPPORT THE LEGISLATION. THAT
COULD IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AND
INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT. YES
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BECAUSE KATE CAL ON
BEHALF OF AMERICAN AIRLINE I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING
CHAIRMAN DR HIS AUTHORSHIP OF
THAT BEFORE SEVENTEEN WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE HIS
LEADERSHIP AND THAT HE
MENTIONED UNDER CURRENT LAW
AIRLINES NOT MOVING IMPORTED
LIVE ALCOHOL THAT IS BROUGHT
INTO ST PROPHETICALLY FOR YOU
ON THEIR AIRCRAFT THE NARROWLY
DEFINED LIMITED AMOUNT OF
ALCOHOL AMERICAN AIRLINES
BRINGS ABOUT THE WHOLE IN THE
TYPE FIFTY FIVE LICENSEE. SB
FOUR SEVENTEEN WOULD CLARIFY
THAT ALCOHOL CAN BE BOTH SOLD
OR SERVED ON AIRCRAFT AND ALLOW
FOR FLEXIBILITY AS FIFTY FIVE
LEIGHTON ADDED OFFERED IN
SEVERAL STATE  HAVE WITH ME
KAITLYN PROVED AMERICAN
AIRLINES LEGAL COUNSEL A
MONITOR DOCU COMMERICAL
AIRLINES YOU CAN ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL. RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY AND THANK.
YOU HELLO MY NAME IS KAITLYN
KRUGER I'M A PARTNER AT THE LAW
FOR CLEARY HERA PENNSYLVANIA I
REPRESENT. AIRLINE THE FIRST
NOW LEAGUE RELATED NOW. THE
BILL IS VERY NEAR IN SCOPE AND
ALLOW AIRLINE TO IMPORT. BE A
TRUCK COME SERVICE TO
PASSENGERS ARCHER IN A LACE AND
AIRCRAFT. AIRLINE HOLD VERY
HIGH THE DOESN'T HELP. THIS
BILL WILL ONLY APPLY TO TAKE
THE FIVE. I'M IN. CARRIER
REPRESENT A VERY PERCENT OF THE-
A EVENING HELD FOR AND THE-
BILL IS. CRAFTED ONLY A TO THIS
GROUP EVERY AGENCIES. THE END
OF THE HERE EVERY IN. AIRLINE
YOU NEED TYPE OF RETAIL EIGHT.
AND THAT THEY ARE ALREADY
REGULATED BY THE FEDERAL AGENCY
THE FAA ADDITIONALLY UNLIKE
MOST RETAIL AGENCIES THE
IMPORTATION SALE AND OUR
SERVICE OF ALCOHOL IS NOT THE
PRIMARY BUSINESS OF THE
AIRLINE. THE PRIMARY BUSINESS
OF THE AIRLINE TRANSPORT
PASSENGERS SAFELY. THE TOTAL
VOLUME OF ALCOHOL DISTURBED IN
THE AIRCRAFT IN CALIFORNIA IS
NOMINAL AND ADDED THE TAX
REVENUE GENERATED FROM THE
INVENTORY IN FACT THE TAXES
REMITTED ARE LESS ANNUALLY THAN
THE LICENSING FEES AMERICAN
PAID TO MAINTAIN THEIR TYPE
FIFTY FIVE LICENSE. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF ALCOHOL ORDERED IN
SERVING CALIFORNIA IS FOR CLUB
OPERATIONS AT THE AIRPORT. ALL
ALCOHOL ORDERS FOR THE CLUBS
WILL CONTINUE TO BE PLEASED
WITH AND THE FILLED BY
CALIFORNIA WHOLESALERS. FOR THE
TAXIDERMY INTERVENE ON CHANGE
BECAUSE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCES FROM OTHER RETAIL
LICENSEES THE AIRLINES ARE
COMMONLY GRANTED STATUTORY.
EXCEPTIONS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THESE EXCEPTIONS INTENDED TO
GIVE THE AIRLINES FOR RELIGIOUS
ISSUES. THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
THE L. SUPPLY. AND NOT TO
CIRCUMVENT THE THREE THAT. WELL
THE EARLY THERE FOR TO A- L. I
THE AIR. THERE ARE PRACTICE
REASONS FOR THE NEED TO IMPORT
ALCOHOL TRUCK SUCH A- THE
LIMITED BALL THEY DID FOR ME TO
BE. ON THE PLANE PER. WERE A
DIFFICULT IF. WITH PREDICTING
THE TYPE OF ALCOHOL THAT WILL
BE CONSUMED BY PASSENGERS EN
ROUTE. INCLUDING BEVERAGE
INVENTORY HAS TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE REALLY AROUND THE COUNTRY
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO SEVEN
FIVE. LEADING FLIGHT SCHEDULE
IN CUSTOMER NEEDS TO THE
INVENTORY IS NOT GOING ON YOU.
I THOUGHT WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY.
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE SELF.
ANYMORE M. Q. S. SUPPORT
MODERATOR. NO MORE. MODERATOR
MODERATOR DID YOU HEAR ME DO
YOU HAVE ANY MORE IN Q. OF
SUPPORT WHAT MESSAGE. IT IS A
MANTRA SAKE SPEAKING ON THE
BRIDGEPORT. HI THIS IS A MINOR
SAKE- I'M A PRODUCT MANAGER
OVER ALCOHOL BEVERAGES ON BOARD
AN AMERICAN AIRLINES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO MORE
READ WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
TO ANY OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE
ANY BODY STANDING UP HERE IN
THE GALLERY DO WE HAVE ANY IN
TWENTY FORTY WHO WOULD SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE. LET'S
GO DOWN TO THE QUEUE DO WE HAVE
ANYONE WHO HAS CALLED IN. TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AND TO
OPPOSE. HE SAYING NINE PARDON
ME MR. WE DO HAVE- LEAD SUPPORT.
IN OUR COMMENT QUEUE FOR THE
TELECONFERENCE. WE DO HAVE
THREE PARTIES IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT TWO WEEKS CAN YOU
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MISTER CHAIRMAN A MODERATOR
UNFORTUNATELY WITH THE
CONFUSION HI THIS IS JOE LANG
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SO I
THINK YOU MIGHT HAVE THREE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. WELCOME TO
THE MISTER LANG WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH THE SUPPORT. CLOSE YOU
MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR COMMENTS
RELATED TO THE OPPOSITION YOU
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AUTHORED THE BILL- JOE
LAND REPRESENTING REPUBLIC.
DISTRIBUTORS ALSO KNOWN AS
YOUNG'S MARKET COMPANY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WELL WE
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AT THIS
POINT- OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH AIRLINE-
FONG LICENSED. WHOLESALERS FOR
DISTRIBUTION PURPOSES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONSISTENT DISCUSSIONS WITH.
BOTH THE AUTHOR STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THE ISSUES
TO BE RESOLVED ARE FAIRLY
TECHNICAL WITH DETAILED- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT WE WILL. BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THOSE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING THAT QUICKLY
BUT IN. IN ITS CURRENT FORM WE
REMAIN OPPOSED BUT HOPE TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUES WITH THE
AUTHOR THE- STAFF IN THE BOXES
SHORT. THANK YOU. MODERATOR TO
HAVE ANYONE ELSE THAT WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. LINE FIFTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIRMAN MISTER CHAIRMAN DR
APPRECIATE YOUR INTEREST IN THE
BILL I APOLOGIZE BUT THIS IS A
BIRD OR TO RECORD HIGH. AFTER
THE CAROLINES FOR AMERICA- THAT
TREATISES FOR ALL THEIR LINES
AND IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THANK YOU GOOD MORNING NO
SENATOR NIELSEN. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS TERRY FLANAGAN
REPRESENTING SOUTHERN GLACIER
WHITE SPIRIT WHOLESALERS. WHO
IS SUPPOSED TO THE BILL IN THE
COMMITTEE HAS ALREADY RECEIVED
A JOINT OPPOSITION LETTER. FROM
THE CALIFORNIA BEER AND
BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS AND THE
WINE AND SPIRIT WHOLESALERS
CALIFORNIA. OF WHICH WE ARE A
MEMBER. OR LATER PREDOMINANTLY
THREE SHIPS A LEGAL CASE FOR
WHY SB FOUR ONE SEVEN WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY BY PASCHAL FOR
USE FOR. A LONG STANDING THREE.
HERE REGULATORY SYSTEM IN.
THESE ARGUMENTS THAT MOST OF
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
HAVE ALREADY HEARD RESPECT
OTHER ALCOHOL BEVERAGE.
PROPOSALS OVER THE YEARS.
CURRENT LAW WHICH HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY PROVIDES AN
EXCEPTION TO CALIFORNIA
ALCOHOL. BEVERAGE LAWS FOR
CERTAIN COMMON CARRIERS BOATS
TRAINS AND AIRPLANES. WHICH
MAKES PERFECT SENSE AND HAS
BEEN A REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
FOR THOSE CARRIERS SELL OR
PROVIDE ALCOHOL. TO THEIR
PASSENGERS ARE CERTAIN
EMPLOYEES. WITHOUT BEING
CONSIDERED AN IMPORTER MAKES
SUBJECT TO IMPORTERS LICENSE.
BUT CONTROLLING SECTION HAS
REMAINED UNCHANGED FOR THE PAST
SIXTY ONE YEARS. WITH THIS. WE
DON'T SEE THE CASE HAS BEEN
MADE FORTY FOR THE RECEPTION
THE- ALCOHOL. SECTION FOR
CALLING CARRIERS YES MISTER
LANG SAID THAT WE WOULD BECAUSE
TO MEET WITH. AND DISCUSS THE
BILL WITH THIS. THE THEY THINK
THERE IS MOST POINT WE SOLVE
THEIR ISSUE. THANK YOU. THANK
IN THE PLAN AGAIN DO HAVE ANY
OF AN OPERA MODERATOR. NINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
DENNIS WILL OF THE BEER AND
BEVERAGE STRIPPING. WE ARE
OPPOSED- WE BY IT INTERESTING
THAT WOULD ABOUT THE MINUTES
COUNCIL. BUT WE'RE NOT ABOUT
DOWN. INVENTORY SO IT MAY NO
LONGER BE IN THE MID MISS. ALL
WE LIKE BUT WE WITH- THE
COMMENTS OF THIS FLANAGAN
MISTER LANG. AND ALSO. YOU KNOW
ARE PART OF THE JOINT LETTER
LAW- AND WE ARE. TO YOUR BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY ANY
OTHER. IN Q. NINE THIRTY YOUR
IS OPEN GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL SKIP UP ON BEHALF OF
ALCOHOL JUSTICE. IT'S DIFFICULT
TO SEE HOW THIS BILL BENEFITS
THE PEOPLE OR THE STATE THE
PICTURES TO BENEFIT THE AIRLINE
INDUSTRY AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
STATE- IT IS SAY ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF SMALL BE REGULATORY
CHANGES AND ALCOHOL CONTROL.
THAT THAT OPEN THE DOOR FOR
WIDER- D. CONTROL. AND SUCH- WE
ARE OPPOSED THANK YOU. AT I'M
SORRY THERE ARE NO THIRD
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE.
THAT EXHAUST YOUR WON'T. ONCE
IN Q. MOTHER TERESA ANYBODY
ELSE IN QUEUE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO COMMENT
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S
RETURN HERE TO THE. THE CHAMBER
HAVE MANY MEMBERS HERE WISH TO
SPEAK. COMMENT OR OBSERVE. ALL
RIGHT SAY NONE HAVE. SENATOR
DODD WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE US
A CLOSE- YES RESEARCHER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- YOU KNOW I HEARD
THE SPEAKERS AT I THINK IT'S MY
REPUTATION TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES TO TRY TO GET. THE BEST
BILL MOVING FORWARD AND BEST
POLICY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE TALK IN THIS
CHAMBERS ALL THE TIME ABOUT
HELPING BUSINESS WITH
OVERZEALOUS GOVERNMENT
REGULATIONS THAT PERHAPS MAKE
IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
DO THE THINGS THEY HAVE TO DO
ON A DAILY BASIS. THE PANDEMIC
IT HIGHLIGHTED THAT THIS IS A
CRITICAL PROBLEM NOT JUST FOR
AMERICAN AIRLINES TO SPONSOR
BUT FOR ALL AIRLINES I SUGGEST
THIS IS A DE MINIMUS CHANGED-
THAT- GOING FORWARD- YOU KNOW I
GET AGAIN MY COMMITMENT TO ALL
OF YOU IS THAT I WILL. WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO SEE IF
WE CAN GET CLOSER BUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOTH.
OKAY SENATE EMERGENCY YOU HAVE
A QUESTION OF THE BILL MOVED TO
THE FIND WE HAVE A MOTION. THE
FACT. SAID TO BORDERS. WE CALL
THE ROLL PLACE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWO SB FOUR SEVENTEEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS FOR FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS DODD HI DOT HI
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN AYE ALLEN.
ARCHER BAKER BARGES ALL RIGHT
ORDERS I BRADFORD GLAZER WESO.
BYE WESO JONES HI JONES CAN I
CAN I AM. PORTANTINO I'M
PORTANTINO I WILK HI BOOK I.
THAT IS A VOTES THEY'LL BE
PLACED ON CALL. THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIRMAN FOR COVERING THAT.
RETURNED TO THE CHAIR. OKAY SO
WILL NOW MOVES I'LL NOT I SKEWS
ME FOR NUMBER FOUR. SB FOUR
FIFTY TWO CENTER GONZALEZ YOU
MAY BEGIN THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING AND
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB FOUR FIVE
TWO WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE AFFAIRS AGENCY. TO
SERVICES FOR STATES DIVERSE
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES BY ESTABLISHING A
PERMANENT STRUCTURE WITHIN THE
STATE TO SERVE IMMIGRANTS AND%
REFUGEES SB FOUR FIVE TWO WILL
CREATE A STATE FRAMEWORK AND
CLEARING HOUSE TO BETTER ASSIST
OUR STATE AGENCIES IN
EVALUATING THEIR PROGRAMS BURKE
SAYS ABILITY AND EFFECTIVENESS
IN PROVIDING SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME AS MANY OF
US KNOW TO APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN
MILLION IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES
COMPRISING. NEARLY ONE QUARTER
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION AND
34% OF OUR WORKFORCE. WELL
THERE LOCAL PROGRAMS AND
GOVERNMENT OFFICES OFFERING
SIMILAR SERVICES TO IMMIGRANTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA LACKS A CENTRALIZED
VOICE IN HELPING US MEET THE
NEEDS OF A LARGE IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE POPULATION. SB FOUR
FIVE TO PROVIDE THE PROACTIVE
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM BY
ESTABLISHING AN OFFICE THAT
WOULD BE DEDICATED TO OFFERING
DIRECT SERVICES AND ADDRESSING
RAPID STATE AND FEDERAL POLICY
CHANGES. CALIFORNIA MUST BE
READY TO REACT EFFECTIVELY S A
NEW FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION AND
THEIR POLICIES LIKE PATHWAYS TO
CITIZENSHIP. PROGRAMS ARE
ENACTED AND ESTABLISHING THIS
NEW AGENCY WILL PROVIDE THE
STATE WITH THE NECESSARY TOOLS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY I
HAVE DOCTOR MENTAL PASSPORT
DISTINGUISHED PROFESSOR AND
DIRECTOR AT THE U. S. C. CENTER
FOR THE STUDY OF IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION AND JOSEPH BLF. THE
DIRECTOR POLICY AND ADVOCACY
FOR CHAIRED LAST TO HELP ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU SENATOR- PARTY SENATOR I
DID HERE ARE THE DIFFERENT
CZECHO BOARD THEY WANTED TO
SPEAK TO THE BILL THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE
GOVERNMENT- JANET DR PARKLAND.
HOSPITAL. MODERATOR IS DR- AND
WHILE PASSED ON ONLINE. ONE
MOMENT MISTER. DR PASTOR IS NOW
ON THE LINE. DR PRESS STORY GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
THIS IS KIND CONSTRUCTION YES
GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANKS I'M
HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF SB
FOUR FIVE TWO HOLD ON ONE
LOCUSTS AND ENGLISH PROFESSORS.
AT W. FOR THE- RIGHT. THE
RESEARCH INSTITUTE. FOR THE
SENATE IN THE STATE AND THEN
THE GRANT ENTRANCE COMMITTEE.
HOME AND. THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
COMMUNICATE WE'RE GOING TO RUSH
FANS AGENCY AN OFFICE IMMIGRANT.
AFFAIRS WITHIN THE- YEAH EMAIL
STUDIES OFFICE AROUND THE
COUNTRY LOOKING. FROM CITY
LEVEL AT THE MOMENT LEVEL
SENATE STATE LEVEL AND WHILE
BARK TO SEARCH. TO AND THAT UP
AS WELL PROVIDING IN WORKSHOPS
AWARDS WITHIN THE STATE AROUND
THE ISSUE NEVER GRANT
INTEGRATION SO LYING IS. DOES
AND JUDGING A NEEDED FIRST AS
COORDINATE STATE INSURANCE IN A
BLAMES AND IT THE LAST YEAR. IN
SOME THAT SHOULD BE A SITUATION
IN THIS AND WE'RE VERY GOOD IN.
FOR THE COMMUNITY THAT WERE
ADDRESSED IN A PIECE PLAN AND
YOU CAN HEALTH BAXEEN NEED
COULD BEEN MORE INTO.
HEALTHCARE BEEN A SORT OF ARE
AND TAKE A LOOK AT COOLEY TOOK
TO SERVICES OF. ASIA IN A WAY
THAT WOULD GAP RABBIT SHE. THIS
CONCERT SUBURBAN LOCATIONS BY
PROVIDING INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT IT MEANS TO DO IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION IN TERMS OF POLICY
AND MOST OF ALL THIS IS NEEDED
BECAUSE WE'RE AN IMMIGRANT
STATE TWENTY FIVE MORE THAN 25%
OF OUR POPULATION IS FOREIGN
BORN ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THEIR
KIDS HAVE AT LEAST ONE
IMMIGRANT PARENTS. AND ALSO
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF OUR
PARTICULAR UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION MORE THAN TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIANS A LACK
LEGAL STATUS BUT ONE THING THAT
YOU CAN MORE ABOUT THE
UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION CAN
CALIFORNIA IS AN EXTREMELY LONG
SETTLED MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN IN
THE COUNTRY FOR A DECADE. OR
LONGER. HOLDEN DEEPLY NOW. IN
COMMUNITIES ARE IN ARE-
FAMILIES ENERGY WE HAVE
SIGNATURE NUMBER OF MIXED DATA
FAMILY. ACTION FOR SOME IN LAST
YEAR CONNECTING RURAL
COMMUNITIES PROVIDE AID I
RECENTLY DEMOCRATS AND ONE PLAN
LISTEN CAN'T. IN WE'VE GOT A
TRIMMING OPPORTUNITY FOR NAP
WE'VE MORE THAN TWO- LONG TERMS
LAW PERMANENT. WHO NEED FIELD
YOU WE- I DID NOT GET TO BE
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T. AND STATE
LONGER KIND OF COOL KERR.
COOLEY AS WELL CALIFORNIA HAS
AMONG WILL BEST CALL ON
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION CERTAINLY
A DEALER OPENS DIPLOMA OWN
CAN'T CLOSER CAN HELP YOU SEE
SYSTEM THERE ARE MANY SCHOLAR
WHO ARE READY TO LISTEN. IN
LEADING THE GAME EXTRA FROM
OTHER. WE CAN THE MOST ACTIVE
ALL IMMIGRANT PARENTS ARE OF
ANY STATE WE ALL HAVE AMONG THE
NATIONS BEST A COMMUNITY OR-
GLOBAL PROVIDERS SERVICE
IMMIGRANTS AND ADVOCATES FOR
IMMIGRANTS THANKS WE'VE GOT A
COMBINATION OF THE CLEAR NEED
IN THE STATE IN FROM THE
POPULATION EIGHT EAGLE AND- IN
TERMS OF APPLIED RESEARCHERS
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WILLING TO
PROVIDE ADVICE. AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMING OFFENSE I
CAN ACTUALLY PROMOTE IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION CAN RESULT IN
POTENTIAL EFFICIENCIES AND COST
SAVINGS BY MAKING SURE THAT. WE
TAKE INSTEAD OF PIECEMEAL
SERVICE COULD CUT NOW AND
REALLY PUT THEM TOGETHER THIS
IS A BILL WHOSE TIME HAS
ACTUALLY LONG BEEN DO IT'S
CERTAINLY A BILL I THINK THE-
PAST NOW CAN WE GET THIS KIND
OF THE AGENCY AND OFFICE AND WE
NEED TO RESEARCH SUPPORTER
COMMUNITY SUPPORT CENTER WE
HOPE OUR COUNTRY CAN LISTENERS
WILL SUPPORTED AS. WELL.
SUPPORT ON S. B. FOUR FIFTY TWO
PLEASE. THANK YOU MR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
FIFTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME- WE DO
ALSO HAVE JOSEPH. ON THE LINE-
IN AS A LEAD WITNESS FOR
SUPPORT IF. HE WAS TO TESTIFY-
THANK YOU. JUST TO BE JEALOUS-
REPUBLICAN ADVOCATE CHIRLA
COLLISION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ABOUT GHOSTBUSTERS AND
IF YOU FOR TO ENTER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT. AND
AT THIS TIME WE DO HAVE MIND
SIXTY ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU AT
THIS POINT TIME WILL LOOK TO-
THE OPPOSITION FOR- S. B. FOUR
FIFTY TWO- I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
IN THE GALLERY- DON'T SEE
ANYBODY AND ROOM ONE TWELVE.
OPERATOR CAN WE MODERATE EXCUSE
ME COULD WE CALL AND SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY. BEWITCHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FOUR FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP FOUR FIFTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR
APPRECIATE THAT- SO WE'VE HEARD
FROM SUPPORTERS IN THE
OPPOSITION SO NOW I WOULD LIKE
TO JUST OPEN IT UP TO WHERE
MEMBERS. OF THE COMMITTEE
ANYBODY WISHING- CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU SHARE ANSWER GONZALEZ
I HAD- JUST A QUICK QUESTION
IT'S IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE-
EFFORT MY DEEP MIGHT BE
DUPLICATIVE- I DO APPRECIATE IN
CONTRAST TO THE BILL I'M GOING
TO MENTION I DO APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING IT THROUGH COMMITTEE-
BECAUSE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED SB EIGHTY FOUR. WHICH
IS ACTUALLY BUDGET TRAILER BILL
WHICH- THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
IN THE AND THE GOVERNOR AND
GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED THAT YOU
KNOW PROBABLY DIDN'T I REMEMBER
ALL THE DETAILS THAT BILL BUT
IT PROBABLY DIDN'T COME TO
COMMITTEE SUFFICIENT YOU. DOING
THE- OPPER PROCESS- BUT- SB
EIGHTY FOUR ESTABLISHED THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE DIRECTOR OF
IMMIGRATION INTEGRATION. TO
SERVE AS A STATE WIDE LEAD FOR
THE PLANNING AND COORDINATION
OF IMMIGRANT SERVICES AND
POLICIES. THE WORK OF THE
OFFICE IS DESCRIBED AS QUOTE. I
THINK THIS IS MIGHT BE FROM
THEIR WEBSITE OR FROM THEIR
CHARTER I'M EXACTLY SURE WE
HELP IMPROVE ACCESS TO STATE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE DRIVERS
LICENSES. COLLEGE ACCESS ADULT
EDUCATION HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
TRAINING AND LEGAL SERVICES
WE'RE ALSO EXPANDING SUPPORT
FOR NATURALIZATION TO FULLY
INTEGRATE IMMIGRANTS. AND SO
THE QUESTION WOULD BE I GUESS
IS YOU KNOW WHAT. WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. THIS AND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR
JONES- THAT WAS UNDER THE
GOVERNOR- THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION BACK IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. AND IT YOUR IN FACT
CORRECTED DID INCLUDE- A
STATEWIDE DIRECTOR OF IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION HOWEVER- WITH THIS
NEW ADMINISTRATION. THAT COULD
BE IT'S NOW VACANT THIS
DIRECTOR DOES NOT EXIST SO WE
DON'T HAVE A DIRECTOR CURRENT.
AND WE WANTED TO INCLUDE-
REFUGEES IN THAT TITLE AS WELL
AND ALSO EXPAND THAT TO NOT
JUST IMMIGRANTS BUT REFUGEE
SERVICES. SO THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS THAT IS
ASKING FOR THIS OFFICE THIS
AGENCY AND THEN YOU KNOW WHEN
WE'RE ABLE TO APPOINTED THEY
SHOULD PASS A DIRECTOR. THEY
CAN THEN CREATE OFFICES THAT
WILL WORK IN VARIOUS ARENAS
EDUCATION SMALL BUSINESS AND
ESPECIALLY AS MENTIONED WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE PRO
ACTIVELY WORKING TO OFFER
PATHWAYS TO CITIZENSHIP.
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR US I
THINK YOU HAVE APPRECIATE THAT
AND- RIGHT THE END PLACE TO DO
REMAIN CONCERNED AND IT IS
DUPLICATIVE IN THAT WE'RE
ADDING ADDITIONAL GOVERNMENT-
THERE'S A QUOTE FROM THE SECOND
BE THEY DID EDITORIAL BACK I
BELIEVE IN THE FALL REGARDING
THE UP THIS UPCOMING
LEGISLATION. LEGISLATIVE SEASON
I'LL JUST READ THE QUOTE REAL
QUICK FROM THERE OP ED
CALIFORNIA HAS PIONEERED PRO
IMMIGRANT LAWS. POLITICAL
LEADERS AND ADVOCATES HAVE
DEMANDED THAT CONGRESS OVERHAUL
IMMIGRATION LAW. WHICH I AGREE
WITH BUT IT ALSO- IF BUT IT'S
ALSO IS THAT ISN'T FULLY AND
ABA TO EXISTING AMERICANS. THE
STATE'S PER PUPIL EDUCATION
FUNDING IS AMONG THE LOWEST IN
THE COUNTRY WHICH I DO DISAGREE
WITH- WE HAVE A WE HAVE
ESSENTIALLY THROWN OUT THE
MASTER PLAN FOR PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND WHILE HIKING THE
COST OF PUBLIC COLLEGES WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO MAINTAIN OUR
FREEWAYS THE WAY THEY REQUIRE
AND ARE SYSTEMATICALLY TURNING
THEM INTO FREEWAYS. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE WHEN
RETURNS IN JANUARY. BUT IT IS
ONE THAT MUST TURN TO THE
QUESTION OF FINANCIAL
OBLIGATION SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
KIND OF SUMS UP MY CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL. AND I DO I DO
THINK YOU THOUGH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS THANK YOU.
DAUGHTER FRAZIER HANKS I CAN'T
SAY I'M SORRY SUSAN- CENTER
RUBIO EXCUSE ME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST I WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND I WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL AND BE ADDED
AS A CLOT THERE WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BY ANYBODY- C. NONE OF
SERGEI IS ALSO SUGGESTED TO BE
FAIR WITH EVERYBODY I'D ASK YOU
TO TAKE A FIVE YEAR SUNSET.
EARS IS- THROUGH NEGOTIATIONS
WITH OTHER AUTHORS FOR I THINK
REALLY APPROPRIATE REASONS
WE'VE EXTENDED THAT TO OTHERS
FOR SEVEN HOURS I THINK IT'S
ONLY FAIR TO WEEKS. TO EXTEND
THAT EXTRA TWO YEARS TO SEE YOU
AS WELL- JUST IN A MATTER OF
FAIRNESS SO- WOULD YOU ACCEPT
THE SEVENTY YEAR SUNSET AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO KEEP CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER TRACKER SHEET
THAT AND YES I WILL ERTAINLY
ACCEPT THAT AND- YOU KNOW AGAIN
I JUST WANT TO SAY- THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR. INDULGING
US ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MATTER- BUT AS WE'VE SEEN
THROUGH COLD IT IN AS DR MONEY
ONE POSSIBLE SAID VERY
ELOQUENTLY- CODE NINETEEN
SHOWED US THAT WE NEEDED MORE
SUPPORT FOR AND AGAIN.
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY AS IT
PERTAINS TO DISASTER RELIEF
FAXING EQUITY IN SO MANY MORE
THINGS AND FOR THAT REASON AS A
PROUD DAUGHTER OF AN IMMIGRANT-
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR. MYSTERY WAS
AT AN END- THE MOTION THANK YOU
CENTER RUBIO- SO WE HAVE A
MOTION MOVED BY SENATOR RUBIO-
CAN WE PLEASE CALL SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL YES THIS
IS FILE ITEM FOR SB FOUR FIFTY
TWO. ACT OUR MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY DOT. BY DOT HI
NIELSEN NO. NO SIR NO ALLEN.
OUR BAKER BORDER. BRADFORD
GLAZER WESO I WAS SO ICE JONES
NO JONES NO KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I
MELENDEZ. PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE
WILK. THE BILL HAS FIVE THERE'S
TWO BILLS THAT THAT BILL WILL
BE PLACED ON A CALL THANK YOU
SENATOR. TO ALLOW MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB SIX EIGHTY FOUR
CENTER HUESO YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
THE BUT YOU COULD DO IT. WHEN
THAT'S FULLY SANITIZED YOU GO
BACK THERE AND DO YOUR THING OR
DO IT FROM YOUR PLACE YOUR CALL.
WE'RE YEAH. YEAH LAW. YOUR CALL
SIR IT IS GOING. THANK YOU MR
THIS. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT BOB THIS MORNING I'M
VERY PROUD TO BE PRESENTING SB
SIX EIGHTY FOR A BILL THAT
REQUIRES THE RESTRUCTURING OF
ENTITIES RELATING TO CALIFORNIA
MEXICO BORDER AFFAIRS AND THE
IDEA IS TO TAKE DIFFERENT
DISPARATE. FUNCTIONS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT DEAL WITH ANYTHING
RELATED TO BORDER AFFAIRS AND
CREATING A COMMISSION AN ACTUAL
CITIZENS COMMISSION THAT WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT
INTO THE STATE'S WORK ON
ANYTHING RELATED TO OUR
CALIFORNIA MEXICO AFFAIRS. AS
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD. CALIFORNIA'S
POSITIONED ITSELF AS A GLOBAL
LEADER THIS IS IN LARGE PART AS
A RESULT OF OUR BORDER WITH
MEXICO. EXPANDED CROSS BORDER
TRADE HAS BEEN INTEGRAL
CALIFORNIA SUCCESS IS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD IN
FACT THE TWO LARGEST ECONOMIES.
IN THE UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA
TEXAS ARE ARE TWO STATES THAT
ENGAGE IN QUITE A BIT OF TRADE.
WITH OF MEXICO BY THE BORDER
REGION IS HOME TO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTION ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING AND OTHER
ESSENTIAL INDUSTRIES THE
SIGNING OF NAFTA AND THE U. S.
MCA HAS EFFECTIVELY TURNED THE
BORDER REGION. INTO THE WORLD'S
MOST IMPACT FULL PRODUCTION
PLATFORMS ALL THIS ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY HAS GENERATED ENORMOUS
ECONOMIC BENEFITS TO THE STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE STILL.
NUMEROUS ISSUES THAT DEAL-
THAT- PLAGUE THE STATE A LOT OF
PLANNING ISSUES ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES. SECURITY ISSUES SAFETY
ISSUES- TRAVEL ISSUES TRADE
ISSUES- IT RECENTLY CONNIE'S
ALONG THE BORDER WITH HIT HARD
BY THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
LAST JULY IMPERIAL COUNTY WAS
FACING INFECTION RATES SIX
TIMES AS HIGH BUT THE
CALIFORNIA RATE AS A WHOLE
PATIENTS HAD TO BE TRANSPORTED
AS FAR AS SACRAMENTO TO RECEIVE
MEDICAL ATTENTION. THE RATES OF
HEALTH CASES PER CAPITA WERE OF
THE HIGHEST IN THE STATE BANNED
IN Y DISTRICT- WHICH-
REPRESENTS A BORDER DISTRICT
AND STATE- WE HAD SOME OF THE
HIGHEST INFECTION RATES RELATED
TO CALL OF IT IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO. OF THESE-
EIGHT COMMUNITIES SOL INFECTION
RATES SOMETIMES AS MUCH AS FIVE
TIMES HIGHER. IN ANY OTHER PART
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY ALTHOUGH
THE BOOK BORDER LAKE REMAINS
CLOSE FOR NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL
THE REGION CONTINUES TO SEE
THOUSANDS OF PEDESTRIAN AND
VEHICLE CROSSERS ARE COMPRISED
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL
WORKFORCE WE CURRENTLY HAVE THE
BUSIEST BORDER CROSSING IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD IT MIGHT BE A
DISTRICT THERE INSIDE YOU SEE
THAT ON. CURRENTLY THREE STATE
ENTITIES EXIST- THAT- THAT
REPRESENT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ON ALL MATTERS
RELATED BORDER AND THAT'S NOT
EVEN THEY'RE NOT EXHAUSTIVE
THEY'RE NOT OLD ROUTE. OF
ISSUES RELATED TO THE BORDER
BUT THEY ARE DELINEATED
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO BORDER
HEALTH. AND SOME AREAS OF
PLANNING AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
TO DEAL WITH SOME OF SHORT TERM
GOALS THAT ARE SET. IN IN
CERTAIN AREAS RELATED TO STATE
FEDERAL LAW. UNDERSTANDING THE
UNIQUE THE UNIQUENESS OF THE
CHALLENGES END OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE PROCESS OF
THE BORDER IT THINK IT'S
ESSENTIAL TO CALIFORNIA. STARTS
TO GET REALLY ORGANIZED INTO
HOW WE DEAL WITH THESE WITH
THESE THE MATTERS RELATED TO
THE BORDER. AND THAT WE- DIP
INTO CALIFORNIA'S VAST
RESOURCES OF TALENT. RELATED TO
A BORDER ISSUES WE JUST HAVE
JUST OF ALL AMAZING. SET OF
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE THAT WE
SHOULD DRAW ON TO HELP LEAD
THIS CONVERSATION AND ESTABLISH
A CITIZENS COMMISSION. THAT
WILL NOT ONLY PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
OF STATE AGENCIES BUT ALSO LEAD
OUR OUR STATE AS A MASTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN AREAS OF.
MEXICAN- INTERACTION SO FIVE I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
EARLIER TODAY US SENATOR WILK
GOT PASSED TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AND I'D LOVE TO ASK THE
SHERIFF THAT WOULD BE POSSIBLE.
AND OF COURSE- I WOULD ACCEPT
THE CHAIRS. OFFER AT AMENDING
THE BILL. TO INCLUDE A SEVEN
YEAR SUNSET. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR AT THIS TIME WILL
BE LOOKING FOR- DO YOU HAVE ANY
SPEAKERS ON THIS BILL- CENTER
HUESO. YES HI MISTER CHAIR AND
BEFORE WE- I ASKED WE HAVE A
SPEAKER KENYA SOME OF THE
BUDGET REPRESENTING THE SENATE
WILL CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. THAT
I BELIEVE I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ON THE VEHICLE BUT BEFORE WE DO
LAST THAT I ALSO WANNA FARE.
AND THE SENATE TO CONSIDER-
LANGUAGE MAYBE IN THE FUTURE.
THAT SHOULD THIS BILL EVER
SUNSET SHOULD NEVER BE EXTENDED
IN THE FUTURE THAT. THAT THE
CURRENT STATE OF AFFAIRS IN
CALIFORNIA BE RETURNED AT SOME
POINT WHEN THE PUT THIS BILL
SHOULD IT SUNSET. THE WE HAD-
IT WOULD I WOULDN'T WANT THIS
THIS BILL TO ELIMINATE OTHER
FUNCTIONS ARE CURRENTLY. I MEAN
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE NUMEROUS AND
THEY'RE JUST BEAR IT AND NOT
COORDINATED. I WOULD RATHER
HAVE THAT THAN NOTHING AT ALL
RELATED TO THE ACCIDENT I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR WHAT WE'LL DO IS TO PASS.
WILL WORK WITH YOUR STAFF
WHAT'S APPROPRIATE WILL BE
PERHAPS AMENDMENTS. AND PASS
THAT ALONG TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS- SHARE COMMITTEE
STAFF- TO- CHECK. THAT OUT FOR
INCLUSION IN THE BILL HAPPY TO
DO THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY MODERATOR WE HAVE THAT.
THE SPEAKER IN SUPPORT OF. SB.
SIX EIGHTY FOUR. YES YOU DO
HAVE CAN USE THE AMERICA ONLINE.
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN CALIFORNIA
REPUBLIC. HORKHEIMER WE ARE
VERY TOP REPORT SB SIX EIGHTY
FOUR OF A CALIFORNIA COMING-
INSIDE THE AGO CLOSER TO
COMPLEMENTARY STARTS AT JOHN
HISTORY OF COLLABORATION WITH
THE MEXICO HAVING WITH THAT NOT
DRIVING MORE THE REGION WE HIGH
OF ECONOMIC AND IN- YOU GATHER
WE HAVE BEEN WITNESS I'LL CALL
THANK GOING BE A HARD BRIDGE
AND- TO CREATE A POINT FIVE
BILLION. YOU THINK FACTORING
THE BY CHAIN IN BECAME A LARGE
MANY DEVICE THERE IN THE WORLD
AND WORKER ALL WORKING
COMMITTEE THIS OF COMING
NINETEEN AND THE AND YOU HAVE
FOUND EFFORT YEAH. REPUBLICAN
AMENDMENTS DON'T WALK ACROSS
SECTORS AND ANOTHER BIRTH IN
FACT I'M NOT GOING NATIONAL
WEEKEND. WE FACE A UNIQUE SET
OF CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE WE ARE UP FOR THE
WEEKEND AND WE ARE CERTAIN THAT
THE CREATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
BORDER COMMISSION WILL HELP
BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN OUR
BOARD MEETING SPEECH
STRENGTHENING LOCAL AND THE TO
MAXIMIZE RETURNS THAT WOULD
DRESS ARE YOU NEEDS CHALLENGES
AND TO HELP. EASY OPPORTUNITY
THAT WILL HELP US INCREASE OUR
GLOBAL COMPETITIVENESS AND WE
THINK THAT OUR WEAPONS BELIEVES
IN THE MATTER AGAIN WE ARE.
BORED SB. SIX EIGHTY FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. I'M LOOKING RIGHT
NOW IN THE GALLERY SCENE
NOBODY. ALSO IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- NOBODY COULD WE PLEASE-
OP MODERATOR. CHECK AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANY SUPPORT. ON THE
LINE- THIS BILL POLICE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. SB. SIX
ELEVEN FOR. THE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. I'M LOOKING FOR- ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I SEE
NOT IN THE GALLERY SCENE DONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL AND SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FOR SB SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION SB SIX
EIGHTY FOUR. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR WILL
TURN NOW TO- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR WILK. OKAY
NOW IT'S ON STATE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO COMMEND
THE SENATOR FOR BEING TENACIOUS
ON THIS ISSUE. EARLIER
ITERATION THIS BILL THAT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT THE GOVERNOR
DECIDED TO VETO. TO HAVING READ
THIS I THINK THAT HE'S ADDRESS
ALL THE CONCERNS- THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAD SO I FULLY
EXPECTED TO PASS A BE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK INSIDE AND I
WOULD. AT THE EARLIEST
CONVENIENCE I GUESS WE'RE
AMENDING THE BILL- WITH THE
SUNSET SO I'LL BE ABLE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
WILK ANY OTHER COMMENTS. SIR
WILL CAN I GET A MOTION FOR ME
PLEASE SO MOVED ALL RIGHT SO WE
HAVE A MOTION- BY SENATOR WILK-
CENTER HUESO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
YOUR INPUT AND HELPING US TO
MAKE THIS BETTER BILL. YOU KNOW
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD AND
INTERFACING WITH- NOT ONLY
REPRESENTS OF OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- IN THE UNITED
STATES BUT ALSO FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS GO TO RESOLVE
PROBLEMS RELATED TO THE SALTON
SEA THE NEW RIVER THAT THE
QUAN. RIVER VALLEY AND-
CREATING- MORTARBOARD ACROSS
THE BORDER CROSSINGS THAT
ENHANCE- TRAVEL BUT ALSO
PROTECT. THE SAFETY OF OUR
RESIDENTS AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE. MUCH MUCH. OF
BETTER HANDLED BY AN AGENCY
THAT FOCUSES ON THOSE ISSUES.
SO THIS WOULD BE A GREAT STATE
STEP FOUR FOR STATE AND LOVE TO
HAVE ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT. TO
HELP MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR. OKAY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIVE SB SIX
EIGHTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST THE
MAN AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DODD ALL RIGHT. DOT I
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE ALLEN.
ARCHULETA BAKER HI BAKER I
PORGES FIVE FOR JUST AYE
BRADFORD. GLAZER WHY SELF IS
WHAT SO I JONES I JONES
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER MELENDEZ DO
YOU KNOW I PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WILK HI. HI THE BILL
HAS TO VOTES- WILL THAT ON CALL.
OKAY AT THIS TIME MEMBER OF WE
ARE GOING TO OPEN UP- THE ROLE
ON EVERY BILL WE'RE GOING TO DO
THIS ONCE BUT THEN. OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE IS
MEETING RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
RUNNING A LITTLE BIT LATE AND
WE WILL WAIT ON SOME OF THOSE
MEMBERS BUT OUT OF COURTESY FOR
MEMBERS THAT MAY HAVE GOTTEN
HERE LIKE WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH- THE CALL LIST AT THIS
POINT TIME SECRETARY GOTTA PUT
ON ONE. ON THE CONSENT PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE OF THE
CONSECUTIVE. BUT IT MEMBERS
THIS IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA.
BRADFORD GLAZER WESO. I WESO HI
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HI. MELENDEZ.
OUR SYSTEM CALL. THE BILL STILL
CALL NOW WILL MOVE TO FILE
NUMBER ONE SB SEVENTEEN BY
CENTER PAN SECRETARY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ON SB SEVENTY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SB
SEVENTEEN CHAIR VOTING I
ADVISED HER VOTING NO ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA. YES BRADFORD
GLAZER. MELENDEZ WILK. SEVENTY
OF THE BILL STILL ON CALL. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO FILE ITEM SKEWS ME FOLLOWED
IN TWO S. B. FOUR SEVENTEEN. BY
SENATOR DODD SECRETARY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE ON SB FOUR
SEVENTY THIS IS FILE ITEM TO SB
FOUR SEVENTEEN ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN. ARCHULETA BAKER HI BAKER
HI BRADFORD. GLAZER MELENDEZ
RUBIO. RUBIO HI I'M CULTURE
BILLS ON CALL WILL NOW MOVE THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B.
FOUR FIFTY TWO BY CENTER
GONZALEZ SECTOR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE IN FOR FIFTY TWO THIS IS
FILE ITEM FOR SB FOUR FIFTY
TWO- CHAIR VOTING HI BY SIR
VOTING NO ALLEN. ARCHULETA
BAKER HI BAKER HI GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD GLAZER MELENDEZ WILK.
ON CALL THE BILL STILL ON CALL
WILL NOW MOVE TO FIGHT ABOUT A
MOTOR FIVE SB SIX EIGHTY FOUR
BY SENATOR HUESO SECRETARIES
OPEN THE ROLE FILE ITEM FIVE SB
SIX EIGHTY FOUR- OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS ALAN. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. BRADFORD GLAZER
MELENDEZ. AWQAF BILLS ON CALL.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA- SERGEANT-
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THESE
OTHER COMMITTEES. WITH THE
PUBLIC SAFETY WE FIND OUT
PLEASE.
IS HE THE ONLY OTHER
ONE WE NEED TO WORK OUT. SHE
STILL PRESIDING. SO WHY DO IT
TWICE I DON'T WANT TO BE I
DON'T WANT TO MAKE THEM WAIT
ALL DAY. I'M WE'RE GONNA DO
THAT FOR YOU. WITH THAT. OKAY.
WHAT'S OPEN THE ROLE FOR THE-
SPECIFICALLY PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE IN THE CONSECUTIVE. I FEEL.
IT'S A TIME THAT IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA BRADFORD TRAFFORD HI
GLAZER. GLAZER AYE MELENDEZ.
KAMALA BALCOM MOVES AT ON CALL
FOR CENTER UNTIL A CALL WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO FILE I'D AND ONE SB
SEVENTY BUT CENTER PAN PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE IN SB SEVENTY
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SB
SEVENTEEN ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA. BORDERS BRADFORD ALL
RIGHT BRADFORD AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MELENDEZ. WILK FALLS
BILL STILL A CALL FNAL ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB FOUR SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR DODD SECRETARY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR SEVENTY THIS
IS FILE ITEM TO SB FOUR
SEVENTEEN ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MELENDEZ. I'M COST AT THE
BILL'S ON CALL FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR S. B. FOUR FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ THIS IS FILE
ITEM FOR SB FOUR FIFTY TWO-
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA REGIS BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MELENDEZ WILK THE BILL STILL
UNCLE WILL THAT WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SIX
EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR HUESO
SECTOR PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE OF
HIS FILE ITEM FIVE SB SIX EIGHT
FOUR ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE GLAZER
GLAZER AYE MELENDEZ. THANK OF.
YOUR CALL SO WE'RE GONNA HOLD-
THE ROLE OPEN. FOR CENTER
MELENDEZ.
FIFTY THE SECTOR
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE OF THE
CONSECUTIVE THIS IS A CONTENT
CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA MELENDEZ. THE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR COULD SET.
MELENDEZ HI THAT'S FOURTEEN
ZERO TERMINATE BILL IS ON WE'RE
GONNA MOVE THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE S. B. SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
PAN THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SB
SEVENTEEN. CHAIR VOTING I'D BUY
EXTRA VOTING NOT I KNOW ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA BORDERS
MELENDEZ. SHE WILL PICK UP THE
MICROPHONE TO STUDY CAN BE
HEARD THEIR SENATOR WELCH
DOUBTS. SO I CAN FIND ONE SB
SEVENTEEN CHAIR VOTING I'D
BITES ARE VOTING NOW ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA FOR JUST
MELENDEZ. WILK THE BILL IS OUT
GERMAN NINETY TWO WHAT DO YOU
WHAT WAS THAT I ALREADY SAID I
WAS JUST BE SEVENTEEN I KNOW
WHY IS HE SAYING EVERYBODY
ELSE'S NAME THEY'RE NOT HERE
MELENDEZ NO ON FILE ITEM ONE
BECAUSE WHEN WE OPEN THE FILE
ANYBODY THAT'S NOT VOTED ARE TO
LET ME HANG OUT HERE CONFUSING
OKAY OKAY FILE ITEM ONE SB
SEVENTEEN MELENDEZ NO. YES
WHAT'S THE NUMBER FILE ITEM ONE
SB SEVENTEEN MELENDEZ NOTHING
NO CORRECT CORRECT CORRECT OKAY
SO THAT'S NINETY THREE GERMAN A
BILL IS OUT THAT BILL WAS NOT
ENTICED THREE KNOWS THE BILL'S
OUT S. FINAL- TWO SB FOUR
SEVENTEEN SENATORDODD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWO SB FOUR SEVENTEEN ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA MELENDEZ HI
MELENDEZ AYE THAT'S FOURTEEN
ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO THAT BILLIS
OUT. ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB FOUR
FIFTY TWO BY CENTER GONZALEZ
FILE ITEM FOR SB FOUR FIFTY
TWO- CHAIR VOTING I'D BY
SERVING NO ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA GORGEOUS MELENDEZ NO
MELENDEZ NO. WILK THAT IS
NINETY THREE. NINETY THREE THAT
OUT WILL NEW TO ADAM NUMBER
FIVE SB. SIX FOUR BY CENTER
HUESO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS
IS FILE ITEM FIVE SB SIX EIGHTY
FOUR ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA
MELENDEZ. THE BILL IS THIRTY
DESERVES THIRTEEN ZERO THAT'LL
IS OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS. WHO
PARTICIPATED PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. GEORGE COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WITH THE MODERATOR
STILL ON THE LINE THANK YOU FOR
A JOB WELL DONE THANK YOU TO
THE STAFF HERE FOR THE SENATE-
INTHE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL EXIT ORGANIZATION.
THIS MEETING IS NOW. ADJOURNED.